foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] em
[Music]
we have a lot to get to it's Monday holy
moly former gang threatening the
minority leader of the Senate Mitch
McConnell because apparently Mitch
McConnell is uh
betting on Republicans losing I think
that's why he's mad
it is a former game yeah there's a lot
of delusional [ __ ] coming out of the
rally which is not surprising that the
America First Nazis uh are coupled to
delusion still at this rally that went
on this weekend not surprising um we
have Ron DeSantis being an absolute
[ __ ] failure ah who could have
guessed it it's almost like someone was
saying it for three or four days about
Ron DeSantis being a [ __ ] failure and
that he would [ __ ] this up
it's almost like that happened I don't
know who would have said that
come on now
it's not hard to know that someone like
Ron DeSantis who does not look at
Americans as human beings but as pieces
of meat
would do this
Lee County is absolutely devastated and
Ron DeSantis is flipping waffles in
Saint Augustine
because you know people in Lee County
they just may not like him
enough for him to give a [ __ ] not only
that we find out that
they weren't even warned with evacuation
and he has the capability as a governor
to warn people in the State of Florida
in those counties
Daryl Licht and Duty I don't know if
you've seen the video
of Fort Myers
I mean look the the ocean
comes into the town and just tears it
apart
I forgot he forgot to he forgot to warn
those folks he just you know slipped his
mind he was concentrating on other
things like shipping migrants to
Martha's Vineyard you get it do you
understand now you dumb [ __ ] do
you understand why it is so important
that you elect someone who has a half a
[ __ ] brain
do you get it do you understand now this
is this is all I can't even believe
we did this [ __ ] back in 2016. we did
this nonsense were we elected a buffoon
a [ __ ]
someone who gives a [ __ ] about no one
but himself
and we we watched how it turned out
and we're gonna see more of the effect
in less than 40 days and we'll be at 37
days until it's until November 8th
we're counting down here
and the country is going to rebuke these
fools
there's there's no Trump base
it's the same [ __ ]
it's the same [ __ ] at the
rallies
dang [ __ ] you want to watch a
crowd go absolutely Bonkers and batshit
crazy
over the potential of someone having a
coherent grasp on government go look at
the styles
uh concert in Austin where Beto appeared
and styles had a Beto sticker on his
guitar
and the app that the stadium which was
[ __ ] packed not this fake Trump pack
[ __ ] where there's they they're buying
plane tickets for the same [ __ ]
to show up and stand outside these uh
these Arenas to get them 10 full and
then they position the cameras just
right so it looks like there's a big
crowd for Grandpa poopy pants I'm not
talking about that kind of [ __ ] I'm
talking about a [ __ ] Stadium that's
[ __ ] packed to the gills
360. not half the [ __ ] not 10 of this
[ __ ]
and the absolute
Madness that happens when when the
camera focuses on the Beto sticker
now my hope is that every single one of
those people that are from Texas that
were there
at that concert that we're excited about
the prospect of having someone in Texas
that is that is Tethered to reality
gets their [ __ ] ass out and gauges in
their democracy
you know we say it here all the time you
know everyone wants to say vote yeah
that's cool if you go vote
but it's a hell of a lot better if you
engage in your democracy and actually do
the things that democracy do
which is lean into the [ __ ] [ __ ] these
fascists [ __ ] Ron DeSantis [ __ ] Greg
Abbott
[ __ ] Donald Trump [ __ ] em
we do not have to stand around and
pretend like their views are half the
country that is not what we have to do
that is not the truth and I'm sick and
tired of them saying it and the media
placating it
let's show these [ __ ]
if they think their [ __ ] positions
are half the country well let's find out
let's [ __ ] find out
this midterm is a good way to do it this
is the first national election
since the sedition
the conspiracy of sedition speaking of
conspiracy of sedition and Trump treason
Stewart Rhodes and The Oath Keepers are
on trial today the jury is selected the
judge said no this jury is not impartial
this is how this [ __ ] works this is how
trials in this country work if you
commit crime you do not get to commit
crime and then claim that you can't have
a jury so you get to run free that is
not how it works that's how it's it it's
never worked that I mean for some folks
but these these Oath Keepers are not
getting away with acting like the jury
is Tainted get the [ __ ] out of here with
that [ __ ]
the judge was not Hamming it this
morning
and this trial is something that that
the Trump orbit does not want to have
happen right now
and really the January 6th select
committee not a postponing their hearing
from last week
because of uh hurricane I ain't in
excuse me hurricane Ian in Florida
because they knew it was going to be
devastating they knew it was going to be
devastating
and they knew it was going to take all
resources to help the people of Florida
unlike Ron DeSantis you know some people
give a [ __ ] about constituents some
people give a [ __ ] about Americans
they don't just see them little ponds in
their political game
but the January 6th select committee
postponed this this last
hearing
and I believe the reason why they're not
excited about having another one is
because you ain't going to need another
one with this [ __ ] trial
folks this trial is right out in the
open
yeah there's not cameras and it's not
all uh done up like the January 6 Select
Committee
but if you don't think this evidence is
going to get out in the public holy [ __ ]
you're out of your mind
this morning we already we already find
out that they're alleging the reason why
they picked the quality in the one they
did was because it was so close to Route
66 which only only made it the easiest
possible route into Washington DC from
across the Potomac
their plan was to be violent with
Weaponry firearms
the qrf as it is
I've had Stuart Rhodes a strange son
Dakota Von Adams on this show several
times I've had as a strange ex-wife
Tasha Adams on this show
and we have asked them
and Stewart is absolutely delusional
and they believed in this delusion that
Donald Trump would [ __ ] pardon them
and make them political allies if they
just made sure he retained power
that was the whole [ __ ] point and
that's what we're gonna find out with
this trial and we're gonna see the
evidence laid before the American people
that's why they didn't want to go to
trial
that's why they didn't want to
they wanted some kind of deal or some
kind of delay past this election
this is gonna be a [ __ ] huge rebuke
on trumpism this election is not about
our Congress and our Senate that's part
of it that's what's at stake here
but this election
this next election the 2022 midterm on
November 8th is about who we are as a
[ __ ] country and a democracy that's
what it's about
and we must we must
focus on engaging in our democracy
and make sure we [ __ ] call these
[ __ ] fascists down for who they are
all up and down the board
rather it's Greg Abbott in Texas Ron
DeSantis in Florida Carrie Lake in
Arizona Blake Masters in Arizona
we have Eric Schmidt here in Missouri
you've got the mission in Michigan
governor's race you've got the senate
race in Ohio where JD Vance
oh Trump was Hitler and now I love
Hitler good nice message there JD hold
him accountable
Dr Oz in Pennsylvania not sure why he's
even running in Pennsylvania he's from
New Jersey Herschel Walker who can't
seem to form a goddamn thought
Val dimmings against Marco Rubio
in Florida where is [ __ ] Marco where
is he where the [ __ ] is he
he's the center of the state of Florida
why isn't he down in Fort Myers to make
sure streets are even clean so they can
pass through to assess the damage they
don't give a [ __ ] they're they're
flipping waffles up in Saint Augustine
where branches were on the ground you
[ __ ]
I told you I [ __ ] doubt me doubt me
it's not hard to even know this [ __ ]
it's not hard to know that Ron DeSantis
is going to be a vile gross piece of
[ __ ] piece of trash because that's what
he is
he's a piece of [ __ ] trash
and he doesn't even need to be anywhere
near any office anywhere
in the government all the way down to
God damn I wouldn't [ __ ] I wouldn't
even consider voting for Ron DeSantis as
dog catcher
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
I wouldn't want him do it having
anything to do with animals he'd
probably torture him and send him all
over the country do all kinds of crazy
[ __ ] with him
he's just that indecent
Jesus Christ that's the bar we've
reached in this country
you [ __ ] Republicans really need to
get your goddamn act together
that the bar the bar for
for any not our two-party system we're
down to one [ __ ] party here and
the bar is decency holy [ __ ]
that's how it's so [ __ ] predictable
you dummies how do you think I predict
this stuff it's not because I have some
kind of magic ball here
it's because it's easy to know who you
are you pieces of [ __ ]
you are predictably unpredictable let's
let's put it that way
and it's time it's time in this country
that we [ __ ] just tell trumpism to go
[ __ ] itself and the best way to do that
is with democracy that's why they're
terrified of it they're [ __ ]
terrified of democracy
Jesus Christ did you hear the [ __ ]
the orange Mussolini Jesus speaking in
his rally oh my God
Jesus [ __ ] Christ and then what he's
posting on fraud social
sending death threats to Mitch McConnell
and saying racist ass [ __ ] I'm a racist
as [ __ ]
about his wife
Elaine ciao
which the reason why he hates her is
because when the January 6 Insurrection
happened she said yep that's enough I'm
I'm not gonna be your transportation
secretary I resigned you're out of your
[ __ ] mind Grandpa you are out of your
[ __ ] mind
clean up the ketchup I'm out of here
and Mitch McConnell is running around
Washington
basically hoping that Republicans lose
because he knows the stakes here
if if Kevin McCarthy becomes the speaker
of the house it is basically it is
Trump's ass puppet
and Speaker of the House
that's what that's when all this noise
has been about about Trump being speaker
is to force Kevin McCarthy to bow down
get on his Cheeto dust knee pads
Jesus Christ or even floating the idea
that Marjorie Taylor green is going to
be the speaker
and she shows up at the rally ah she's
his best buddy
now that they're getting a divorce
from from her husband
which that's all to protect their
[ __ ] family business
and the fortune they've made off
exterior construction in Georgia
that's that's what I've gotten to
conclusion of
that and the Q Anon [ __ ] but oh boy was
the Q Anon [ __ ] on full display at the
Nazi rally this weekend oh [ __ ]
Cuban on this queuing on that well it's
the same [ __ ] q and honor so why
wouldn't it be
why wouldn't it be
oh holy [ __ ] you know this morning when
I was developing the title the title of
this episode in some places is Oath
Keepers on trial for Trump treason
Facebook I gotta tell you I wanna I
wanna be totally transparent here
Facebook would not let me use that title
I'm not [ __ ] you they wouldn't even
let me use the title Oath Keepers
on trial versus Edition like just this
just the fact like just that Facebook
wouldn't let me use it
you know it's funny these right Wingers
always complain about they're like oh I
mean censor to being canceled that blah
blah blah yeah get the [ __ ] out of here
I couldn't even use the title Oath
Keepers on trial Force Edition
Facebook lit wouldn't let me use it and
they were like uh pick a different title
[ __ ] and I'm like all right I'll take
the Trump treason out I figure that's
what was triggering it right that's why
Facebook was triggered
[Laughter]
the Russian assets were treasure
triggered by Trump treason so I took
that out
and I just typed I I changed it to Oath
Keepers on trial Force Edition
they still wouldn't they're like nope
nope still not good enough Tony
oh that's that's way too inflammatory
and I find it funny and and I just wiped
the whole title on Facebook all together
so if you're over on Facebook the reason
why there's it just says just the show
name and the number is because I ran out
of time I was up against the clock here
and I was trying to get the damn thing
to degenerate so you guys can see me
live on Facebook because you know we
brought gas live every single weekday as
long as we're not banned or they're not
kicking us up because of our titles
every single weekday noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific for two full hours
Monday through Friday
on YouTube Twitter and twitch and
sometimes sometimes as long as I get the
title right on Facebook and don't forget
to follow us on all the platforms don't
forget to follow us on all of them
including YouTube you also want to go
over follow us on Twitter at Tony
Michaels POD at the Tony Michaels and
that I am Gabe Sanchez my co-host
account over there download every single
episode jeez Louise the downloads are
going up and up and up and up this
audience is getting huge
Apple Spotify Google
wherever you get your podcast download
every single episode every single
weekday
don't forget to follow us on Facebook
at the Tony Michaels go follow my page
over there I broadcast from the Midas
touch page and by page so for whatever
reason if you don't see a broadcast
somewhere
you can always go to Twitch too so
follow us over there
but if you really want if you really
want to make sure you see us go to
Tony Michaels dot live Tony Michaels dot
live you'll see us live there every
single day we've broadcast there you can
also because we run on your support
rather it's liking subscribing
retweeting emailing episodes downloading
them sending to your friends your family
your co-workers your trumped up Uncle
Earl to get him some [ __ ] truth
inside his ears and his brain like old
fake Gabe does over here on Facebook I
don't know if he's here today I haven't
really looked at comments yet
but if you want to go to Tony
michaels.live we run on your support
all the merch store is there you can see
the merch merch sales have been way
through the roof you guys love this new
merch
the uh the Ron DeSantis can go [ __ ]
himself and I got a brand new piece of
merch for you today that I think you're
gonna like
if you've been waiting on that perfect
design that perfect Tony Michael design
but you can go to Tony Michaels dot live
you can leave us a tip there one time
tip or you can set it up each month we
run on your support this is how we do it
this is how we do it this is how we do
it I don't know
but you guys have loved the merch the
dark Brandon merch that's probably the
favorite right now our exclusive Tony
Michaels podcast design of dark brand
and get t-shirts hoodies coffee mugs and
stickers you can also uh get Rhonda
Santos can go [ __ ] himself right now
this one's back there because he
absolutely
can go [ __ ] himself but we got a special
we got a special design that I'm gonna
announce today so stick around don't go
anywhere I'm gonna show you a design
today today but we got a lot of news to
get through there's a lot of [ __ ] that
happened over the weekend
um we have we have the Lee County
um story about Rhonda Santos absolutely
failing the people of Florida
um and just leaving them out in the cold
in Lee County not giving them the
warnings that they should have gotten
we have Tesla dropping today they're
stack dropping Elon Musk losing more
money now Kim Kardashian apparently is
going to have to pay speaking of the
stock market
is going to have to pay some uh
some fines because of crypto Maggie
Haberman is trending also section 230
but David Petraeus is also trending I
believe this is a huge piece of news
that is probably going to be missed and
swept underneath the rug we know that
Vladimir Putin and the the Republicans
vladi Daddy
I love Vladimir ah the Republicans
Decker Carlson the trumpers they love
Vladimir they hope he sends a nuclear
weapon over here
and fights us they want their vladdy
daddy to fight the United States of
America and its allies what a bunch of
dumb [ __ ] you [ __ ] traitors
here's the thing Vladimir Putin uh
decided he would fake Annex right he
would fake Annex some territories in
Ukraine because he's getting desperate
he needed to show the Russian people
that he had some kind of Victory which
is not a real victory it's all excuse
the language trumped up
David Petraeus
and I know the history of David Petraeus
is that he mishandled some classified
information with an author who he was
having sex with
and he was having an affair with
um and he he he pled guilty to a
misdemeanor to disa mishandling
classified which he should know better
he was the goddamn director of the CIA
for crying out loud
it's almost like the director of the CIA
or like a president United States would
should understand how they can again not
handle last fight information
more on that maybe
more on that story but David Petraeus
says that Putin is on the run here it is
very odd that Vladimir Putin would fake
the annexation of Ukraine territories
when they're in retreat
and the other thing too that David
Petraeus said over the weekend is that
basically if Vladimir Putin wants to
actually do nuclear war the United
States and its allies would absolutely
Crush Russia within a matter of days I
think that's now more clear than ever I
think Vladimir Putin is showing his his
his
absolute desperate attempt to remain in
power
um it is he's clinging to it I don't
know when he'll eat the ammo sandwich
but it seems as if it's coming soon
to a theater near you
um Vladimir Putin
is in a lot of big trouble here with his
him being overly confident
about what he could and could not
accomplish in Ukraine
and it's going to be his undoing David
Petraeus believes that
I mean you know the fact matter in David
Petraeus said this out loud in this way
the fact of the matter that Russia has
lost more
times more like several times more
of their army than they did in
Afghanistan
in the 1980s is very significant
and it only goes to show you
that authoritarian regimes don't really
focus much on National Security they
only focus on their own security
because authoritarians are that way
that is how it works that is why tyrants
and authoritarians usually see
a very
not so great
ending
Gaddafi
Hitler
Mussolini
Saddam Hussein these tyrants really do
in the end
get absolutely gobbled up
by people
because the people aren't going to have
this [ __ ] we even see this down an
election in Brazil where there's going
to be a runoff
there wasn't a 50 percent
vote it's about 48 I think is the number
48 are a little over 48 for Lula I
believe is the the name of the the left
wing or socialist that's what they're
calling oh he's a socialist because he's
not a Nazi you know anyone who's not a
Nazi in this world
to anyone now is is a socialist oh
you're a socialist Liberals are
socialist well not all the time but you
know sometimes
but anyways I digress from that
but it looks like we're gonna have a
runoff in Brazil and that their Trump is
gonna lose
he lost big time in the margin
what I mean by that is there was a hell
of a lot more votes against him than for
him sounds familiar
sounds familiar
and we must we must get this as a rally
cry the same thing happened in Italy
everyone thinks Italy is now some kind
of fascist State again no
if you look at the election there folks
the reason why Italy elected a
right-wing the new Mussolini
I think her name is Maloney which is you
know fitting Maloney Mussolini sounds
similar
the reason why she was elected is
because what we think of in this country
is independent Centrist moderates you
know non-politically Affiliated folks
voters they didn't go vote
they didn't engage in their democracy
and what happened
a fascist takes over wants to turn it
into a fascist state
so you must engage it's a thing you have
to do if you want to keep your way alive
in this country the way you got it you
know that nice job you got
the the school that your kids go to
you know the nice little church that you
might attend
the community center that's there
you know all the things that you enjoy
in this country
on television in the library
you know on the magazine rack in the
grocery store even
all those all that Liberty you enjoy
that you really don't know exists
because of our system
they want to take it away from you they
want to take it away
they don't give a [ __ ] about you
they don't give a [ __ ] about you
and there's a prime example happening
right now in Florida where Ron DeSantis
predictably easily predictably by the
way
is going to treat certain Floridians
different than others because he doesn't
give a [ __ ]
about certain Floridian if you don't
like him he doesn't like you he didn't
give a [ __ ] then give [ __ ] so much so
that he won't even send out a warning to
evacuate an area that he knows is just
going to get hammered by a deadly storm
knows it
hmm
that's the choice you have
this next month going forward
and you have a month to do it check your
registration get your friends check the
registration register people to vote why
you still can
engage in your democracy speak about
these issues
tell people the [ __ ] truth
yes Ron DeSantis is a [ __ ] box
why elect anyone who is even has a whiff
of what Ron DeSantis is selling
which is Banning Book Fairs Banning
books focusing on children's genitalia
and their sexual identity they are
[ __ ] weirdos in Tennessee they want
to marry children for crying out loud
they want to take away women's rights it
won't stop at their uterus either
they're coming after their vote trust me
they don't like tonight 19th Amendment
they don't like the 19th it's not the
first of the second or the fifth so it
really doesn't serve their purposes
especially when women have rights to
vote against them
they don't really like that kind of [ __ ]
and want to do away with that thing
where women have rights
doubt me
the Supreme Court here's another story
the Supreme Court is opening their
session today and one of the one of the
cases is they're gonna they're going to
slam voting rights
so you better start [ __ ] voting you
better start engaging your democracy why
you still got it
because that's the signal we have to
send we can't just beat them
we can't just win by a half a percent we
have to pile mountains mountains of
votes on top of these [ __ ]
fascists mountains
just destroy them
in the polls
it's time
and we're here doing it every single day
so come listen every single weekday
Monday through Friday two full hours
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on
YouTube Twitter and twitch and
simulcasting on the books of face
everyone stick around we're gonna go
through the [ __ ] list Roundup there's a
lot of news a lot of Clips to get
through from the week and I don't even
know if we'll get to all of it we only
got two [ __ ] hours how am I gonna get
to all this [ __ ] we'll be right back
right after these messages [ __ ] let's
round up as soon as we come back
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product hard and blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking around through the
break you're the best audience in the
damn world that's right the best damn
audience in the whole wide world right
here at the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
yeah I stick through brakes you stick
around you come here every single day
listen to me yelling scream into the
microphone to save democracy
and really it's up to you it's not up to
me I'm just here to try to help you
cathartically get through this
situations the situations and boy did we
have a situation this weekend Gabe
Sanchez did we have a crazy situation
this weekend uh where um grandpa
Poopypants not only does he send a death
threat out on uh fraud social to Mitch
McConnell but he um
he got on stage at one of these America
First Nazi rallies and said some just
crazy ass [ __ ]
yeah
yeah the guy is it gets exhausting it's
exhausting he's losing his marbles we'll
just say that well like I say he is
marbles packed their [ __ ] and they left
they did he didn't have time to lose him
they [ __ ] left the long damage well
the other the other thing too is just
like you have the pressure from an
investigation from Leticia James 200
million dollars suing not only him the
organization but also his three adult
children
uh which I love with how they call it
his adult children
uh and then in addition to that you mean
they're adults and they're responsible
for their own [ __ ] but I think I
could actually phrased that way to say
adult children like you've got all these
adult children not not like you're like
well I mean they act like children well
yeah totally right uh but anyway so
there's that pressure you've got the
Georgia case you've got uh now this
um
the documents case right oh buddy do we
every everything is coming from all over
uh on on him and do we have anything new
on the documents case this morning
because I I was trying to pay attention
to the Oath Keepers trial
um and I know I know doj is trying to
um seek some kind of like look this is
this judge Cannon is not normal right
and she was our bonehead she was on bone
end of the week poll the last few weeks
but she won last week because of her
dumb decision to while she appointed a
special master and then was like oh yeah
by the way that's I'm not gonna I'm just
gonna overrule and be the special master
myself uh sorry people say that I sound
too low here yeah yeah you might want to
turn up here I think your volume sounds
too low
turn that [ __ ] to 20 baby get it to 20.
let's just get it give me up keep going
up up
yeah you need it you need to eat that
microphone one of the other people said
sounded fine to them maybe people don't
have headphones and I don't know I don't
know we're good you know we're trying to
work the volume here it's very difficult
because we're remote and we're on a
software that that is remote so it
doesn't I'm at uh how is that better oh
yeah I think it sounds great it's not
that I need a better mic it said I just
have the I've got a fan going on in my
room so I won't get the game down
competing with it
people can hear me people can hear me it
might be here let me see if I can turn
mine down
let me turn mine down that might be an
issue here there we go
let's turn it down and I'll get there we
go
now now how's that now you talk Dave
I'll talk I think now how now how does
it hello it's Monday
it is Monday what a [ __ ] Monday huh
oh man I'm not I'm not peaking
well they're saying I'm louder because I
think that's the problem here is it's
the volume level
and it depends on where you listen to
folks because the audio the audio is is
compressed differently at different
places so like on Facebook they can
press the audio a little differently
than YouTube or twitch or Twitter they
do they do they do change it a bit
um as we go because they run the audio
through a compressor on their live feed
so right right it is sometimes when
you're when you're simulcasting
um anyway I just wanna I just wanted to
fix it today well I want to point out
thank you pam pam on Pam on Facebook
says Tony you're louder than just about
anyone that is true I've been accused of
that a timer too I'm not going to say
that's not the truth I would admit my my
great fantastic voice carries all the
way from here to the microphone a lot
and I get a little loud and excited
sometimes I'm not gonna lie that's how
you do I do I get pissed off but and I'm
pissed for you though and Gabe there's a
lot to be pissed off about over there is
yeah there's a lot there's a lot that
has uh that has happened over the week
we got a lot of video to get to
um and I want to get to some of this
trunk that rally
um video but I also want to get to the
the the post about Mitch McConnell the
death threat that he sent out
um Friday for Saturday night oh man it's
it's tough to keep track anymore this
guy he just he's off the rails
um he just it it's it's firing out of
control because we also have news more
news on this documents case so this new
lawyer is kind of against the other
lawyers this new lawyer is like hey
buddy you're [ __ ] you need to shut
that [ __ ] up Chris Case
yes or sorry Chris Chris Keys Chris Keys
yeah
so yeah the quick the the tldr is uh and
I actually covered this in the in the
latest what was that but uh basically
they hired Chris keys he was a Florida
defense attorney they paid him three
million on a retainer this is the
biggest amount that they paid in in the
history of their time with the Super PAC
save America
and they paid 3.8 million in the month
of August 3 million went to the retainer
that went to Chris keese and since then
he hasn't listened to Keith's [ __ ]
once he hasn't done anything he's like
Yo dude cool it down dude we need to
[ __ ] cool this down you need to not
be so reactive you need to stop talking
because this is going to get you in
trouble and Trump can you imagine though
trying to tell Trump to shut the [ __ ] up
I mean really honestly I mean what what
makes anyone think at this point anyone
right to have to have the kahunes to go
to [ __ ] Grandpa poopy pants who is
off the rails lost his marbles he's out
there in left field what whatever
whatever kind of little phrase you want
to use this guy is just [ __ ] here and
try to say hey man you really need to
you really need to get the ketchup off
the wall and calm down a bit
yeah I don't think this is gonna work
yeah he didn't he he hasn't not he has
not I mean like here's the thing Chris
kais or sorry Chris keys he got paid he
got his money so he's just kind of
sitting on the sideline doing nothing
but he got his three mil so they're just
like whatever I gave you advice who gave
him the three mil who gave him the three
does it save America
so you're telling me you're telling me
this is what I go into so you're telling
me
that Donald Trump supporters gave him
money to to run in 2024 and he's using
it to cover his ass for the Espionage
and the treason he committed on just
this one case for the documents so
they're supporting not only uh out in
public but financially they're
supporting his his treason don't you
think that's the reason why they still
hold these rallies
oh yeah 100 yeah I mean I mean because
because this save America pack is
interesting I know you're gonna do a
what was that on it but maybe we should
get into this a bit today because I
think this has a lot to do with him
flailing at these rallies
um this isn't this isn't just he I mean
it is that he likes to go in front of
these crowds but these crowds aren't
they're they're not that big they're not
big at all they're not filling these
[ __ ] venues that that heavily and I'm
gonna show you a venue that was actually
packed to the gills and cheering for
better O'Rourke I'm going to show you
that video today this is [ __ ] nuts
um I mean it's kind of crazy that Harry
Styles has a has a a [ __ ] sticker on
his guitar in the entire Arena just
erupts
um it does say something about who is
actually popular right now in this
country
but it feels like to me that more than
anything the save America America First
Nazi rallies the the the fun the the
fraudulent fund and I I know they're
changing it right because they're trying
to move money around trying to move that
choke around but but here's the thing it
feels like to me
that this is a way for him to basically
um take the opposite of Cree Chris
kise's Chris Keys whatever his name is
his lawyers uh uh actual stance on not
saying anything it is an actual chance
for him to get out in front of his
people to keep these donations coming
because we know that is his pack only
got 40 bucks and 40 not 40 million not
40 000 40 bucks yeah four bucks
so they're trying to move things around
they're trying to you know launder more
money I'm sure
um to keep him going but let's do this
let's go to shitless Roundup I'm going
to show you some of these videos Gabe uh
from over the weekend and one of them is
this most devastating video of of uh
it's a time lapse of Fort Myers in
Florida yeah crazy it's crazy I can't
even believe
they weren't sent a warning they were
not sent to warning well I think some
people on social media were saying they
were sending them a warning like as the
water was rising to three feet is when
they were getting a warranty look out
you know it's like oh that's right no
[ __ ] Sherlock right so let's do this
let's round up the Tweety tweets and the
20 Trends let's start the [ __ ] list get
the countdown going
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
about the Tweety tweets and drink Trends
we got a big audience today it seems
like Monday's heavy I don't know just is
that just me it seems like money is
heavy on the live audience people like
look yeah whatever the hell happened
over the weekend we got to figure out
what the hell is going on well I think
Tony's gonna go through the Tweety
tweets and the trendy Trends so yeah I
think people are coming in for the more
or less the the the weekend breakdown
kind of catches me up what's going on
right I had to assume right there's a
lot here's the thing there's a lot of
stuff that happens between
as soon as the show ends on Friday right
at 11 or at my time 11 A.M uh but when
it ends and when Sunday rolls around
through you're like holy [ __ ] I've
already well even up until Monday
morning because even this morning we
have a lot of news with the Oath Keepers
this trial ticking on and I think that's
one reason why we're not going to see
the excitement of a January 6th select
committee I think the January 6th
selectomy is like I don't know if we're
going to be able to compete with The
Oath Keepers trial like I just don't
know if that that's gonna be able to be
a competition because Benny Thompson
um just just I think it was on Friday
before they went home for the weekend
said he doesn't expect to have a hearing
next week they they're going to decide
on when to have a hearing it sounds like
we're only going to get one
and they're really not there it doesn't
sound like it's gonna have Genie Thomas
it really sounds like what they want to
do is the ride or stone stuff but the
problem is you're gonna see a lot of
this [ __ ] in The Oath Keepers trial I
think that's why they wanted to do the
hearing before the trial to get some of
this evidence out into the open to get
people talking about it before they seen
it in a federal courthouse because
here's the difference
the the information the evidence that's
going to come out of the federal court
case that the the criminal case of
criminal uh conspiracy of sedition right
is not going to be publicly broadcast
like the select committee so I think
their goal was well let's get what we
know they're gonna talk about and get
that narrative out there and then we had
the hurricane come in and they actually
you know
they value humanity and right you know
so so they kind of backed off a bit and
said we need to put all of our efforts
and focus into Florida and make sure the
government is fully fully focused on the
travesty that's about to hit Florida and
you know that's crazy that politicians
would actually have some empathy that is
funny well you would assume you know but
we know there's a pretty low standard
set by the Republican party where it's
true you go [ __ ] yourself well and
that's kind of the way that they look at
their control I want to show you this
video here and this is a pretty much a
go [ __ ] yourself moment I'm not going to
play the sound but here's the video as
it goes this is a time lapse I can't
even believe like when the person
mounted this camera wherever they
mounted I'm not sure if this is a
security camera or what this is
I feel like it has to be a security
camera or something because this as we
see throughout this video like they it
it goes through all of the conditions
wind water like whatever it is has to be
mounted pretty securely I feel like
right well and it's got to be pretty
high because at first it looks really
high and then as you see as this time
lapse goes on as the ocean moved in
because here's I mean it's
it is it is crazy to see this kind of
you know second hand but it's it's crazy
to see like this is a [ __ ] current
this is the ocean right moving I don't
know I don't know how far this I would
have to imagine the beach is probably
pretty close to where this is but even
so like that's a lot of [ __ ] water
that is now just come into this area and
just it's not just like oh here's a
current and like the tide comes in and
goes out this is like oh this is like
moving further and further yeah
I've seen some of the and maybe other
people as well and yourself but I've
seen some of the videos of people who
live off the beach and they're like the
water is gone I've walked out a half
mile to a three-quarter mile out and
it's a dry bed of just the life under
like that was under the water
uh and it's like we can walk out no
problem and a lot of people are like
this is really scary because we don't
know if that water is really going to
find its way back as quickly as it left
you know
Oh you mean now that the the storm has
gone right yeah well in it it just gets
worse in this video yeah I mean yeah now
you can barely see the top of these
trees now
um last week because I never experienced
a hurricane I've never lived on a Coast
or uh in a hurricane
um devastated area I I have experienced
floods before right in in Missouri we do
have floods and I compared it to a flood
but after watching this video I want to
apologize for comparing this to a flood
because this is not a flood this is the
ocean moving Inland
um now it is flooding technically but
this is not like you know water has
crept out of its area out of its
Waterway this is literally the ocean
came in now the most devastating part
about this whole thing is that the lines
are lost and the reason why is that we
know now is because Ron DeSantis which
again
I told you last week he was going to be
dare licking his duty because he's a
piece of [ __ ] and he's not hard to
predict that he's a piece of [ __ ] and
the piece of [ __ ] did not warn the
people of Lee County and Fort Myers that
this storm was going to be as bad as it
was and it's the reason why there's
death there and and I bet bet bet
that Ron DeSantis will downplay the
death uh from this hurricane just like
he downplayed the death from the
pandemic in his State and he lied about
it he's gonna lie he's gonna be a snake
he's even he's even showing up in
campaign shirts and to to flip waffles
in Saint Augustine now there was there
was property damage and stuff in St
Augustine but when you look at the
pictures of what happened to Fort Myers
compared to the branches that were down
in Saint Augustine there is no
comparison and why the governor
of Florida Ron DeSantis thought that it
was a good idea to go to Saint Augustine
and flip waffles a place where it was
sunshiny 70 degrees there was a few
branches on the ground where he didn't
want to appear in front of a camera to
show how devastated Florida was what a
vile piece of trash that he that he
knows what happened to Fort Myers and
the deaths down there are his fault he
knows it he [ __ ] knows it that's why
he won't go down there that's why
immediately like that's it it is a
tactic for anyone to use if there is
ever a problem it's like when you get
into a car accident right you never want
to be the first one to say sorry because
that immediately puts you at fault and
this is another situation like that
which is he doesn't want to acknowledge
he doesn't want to say oh [ __ ] we could
have done something better or we could
have uh alerted people sooner or we
could have gotten resources and people
in there to help get the elderly out
right none of that stuff if he doesn't
acknowledge it and he puts his focus on
the areas that were somewhat damaged but
he shows him out there helping the
community and giving resource and
flipping [ __ ] flapjacks
then people you know hopefully his goal
is like if I show myself here nobody
looks over there right and I and I don't
think that's going to be the case here
right you've got a ton of people who
have who the bodies continue to pile up
in terms of the number count for debts
you've got an area that is completely
devastated and has been just ransacked
by the rain the water uh wind like you
saw that house it started in one
position and it was completely gone like
it left the screen oh yeah the ocean
picks that house up and and and carries
it off and it's gone it's just
absolutely gone and that that is the the
type of Devastation that you see in the
aerial shots which uh I looked at the
arrow shots early on
and it was hard to kind of figure it out
because I don't know what I don't I mean
I'm I'm ignorant as as in what Fort
Myers looks eerily right I didn't know
what it looked like before but when you
actually see the video and the photos
when these people are trying to clear
the roads in Fort Myers to try to try to
figure out okay what the hell is even
left
um
the most devastating thing they're
trying to find missing people which is
just heartbreaking because the governor
of the state of Florida and and really
any state in general in this United
States has access to the emergency
uh weather system and what that means is
is that a governor can activate and tell
the weather system that they can tell
them send out a warning and with the way
that we have technology now and I don't
know if anyone's ever received an amber
alert
um on their phone or a storm warning on
their phone some apps that you download
have the storm warning in and of itself
in the app but the government
the government Gabe and again this is
why it is so [ __ ] important that we
don't put [ __ ] boxes in charge of
government the government is the one
that is in charge and gives the
authority to send out those warnings
during these periods of time when
there's these storms and Ronda santis
did not do that he didn't do it until
after the fact now I don't give a [ __ ]
regardless of you know who it is what it
is where it is I don't give a [ __ ] I
don't care and the Stark difference that
you're gonna see is you're gonna see Joe
Biden go down and not care who what who
these people voted for he is not gonna
give a [ __ ] to him they are people who
live here in this country in a state and
they are devastated by a storm and I and
from the very beginning Joe Biden has
done everything he could even early on
declaring a disaster before the son of a
[ __ ] even hit Coast because he knew
what was going to happen
um and that shows you real leadership
the other thing the other thing that's
really funny Gabe is did you notice did
you notice that it's not just a
republican Ron DeSantis the governor of
Florida that's such a piece of [ __ ] here
that the representatives the Congress
people voted for people in Florida not
to receive the extra funds that Congress
did you see this I did I said what in
the [ __ ] is going on it I mean whether
it's Matt Gates or Marco Rubio or Rick
Scott or uh uh I don't know who else I'm
blanking on right now but those are the
people that come to mind right now in
terms of who actually were voting
against the FEMA Aid or voting against
actually getting support to their
constituents you know I think what was
it Matt Gates didn't want to give
funding because it would give Joe Biden
a win before the 2024 election assuming
that he runs right or would he it would
give Democrats a win before the midterms
like what does this have to do with
winning and losing elections this is
[ __ ] this is people you pieces of
garbage the fact that again like this is
the same thing that we saw last week and
the week before which was using these
people the like you know these
Venezuelans who were seeking Asylum
using them as pawns and this is another
moment where it's like ah you know what
can't can't don't want to give that area
funding because if we do then we might
lose that voting block because it'll
show that Democrats actually care about
saving lives regardless of where they
are on the political Spectrum right
regardless of who they voted for right
they don't care they just care about
saving human life just you know a thing
that humans
Christians should do but in this
scenario they don't want to give them
the W they don't want to Republicans
don't want to give Democrats the W for
doing their job for saying hey we should
give this state funding and the
resources they need to save these lives
and they said if we do that
then Democrats will have leverage to
show that they actually care
so what we need to do is we need to vote
against it but we need to play the game
that votes or blames democrats for not
doing their job which is the complete
opposite they don't want to do their job
they don't want to help people as
Republicans they just want to [ __ ] over
Democrats to own the libs which is the
dumbest [ __ ] I've ever heard to continue
to use people's political Pawns so that
Democrats don't get a win this isn't
about getting a win this isn't about
getting a w in there in their column
this is just about caring and saving
human lives and Ron DeSantis and Rick
Scott and Matt Gates and Marco Rubio are
all incompetent uh lawmakers that are
that are not actually representing the
constituents of Florida
I'm trying to find this video of Marco
Rubio no no [ __ ] Marco I I could care
less about his dumb ass there's a
Florida congressman and I forget this
[ __ ] [ __ ] Box's name he's a
republican not surprising that he's a he
[ __ ] is dehumanizing people of
Florida
um but he's on Fox and he's talking
about how Joe Biden has not accepted I
know who you're talking about the
Declaration a major is that what is this
the guy that was doing the gun thing
this is the one who said and I made that
joke about the Scooby Dooby Doo yeah
[ __ ] thing yeah yeah yeah
exactly that is who it is here I'll find
that Scooby is it is it smell like
Scooby yes no s-t-e-u-b-e
but yeah he's the guy who had the gun in
the video he's like look I got this gun
and I got that gun and I got this gun
and I was like this guy's gonna [ __ ]
shoot himself
he is something else uh because he's on
Fox News and he's talking about how he
sent here it is yeah ace at it here but
he signed he signed a declaration of
major disaster or something which
Congress people don't declare and not
only that but it's that same type of
rhetoric that that I was commenting on
last week which is Ron DeSantis
it it's not even a conversate like when
he was on Tucker Carlson Ron DeSantis
said oh well I requested these these
expenses be completely reimbursed and
this and that like I I put out the
request so Joe Biden better acknowledge
it it's like wow he didn't need to
because one he was already on it and two
when he sat you down you said yes Mr
Garden yes Mr President yes yes well
because he wants he wants that money so
he can funnel it to his to his own
people exactly oh he's absolutely Ron
DeSantis there's going to be
investigations into this FEMA money
around Ron DeSantis for sure if
Republicans have anywhere near socialist
money they're stealing that [ __ ] they're
stealing it they love socialism when
they get to [ __ ] steal it here's
here's probably a socialist Thief here
um this is this is Scooby-Doo uh
Congressman Scooby-Doo here he's on I
don't know Fox [ __ ] whatever show I I
don't know at this point it's Trader TV
but the even the host is like wait wait
is that what what's a major your
disaster declaration what is this that
you're talking about here uh let's see
make sure I got the volume at well let's
watch I don't have power cell Services
spot I knew this was gonna be can you
can you hear it there yeah you got to
bring it up for people and let's see but
it pales in comparison to the rest of my
district uh the mass majority of my
district does not have power uh cell
service is very difficult uh myself and
Senator Rubio are going to go out to
Hardy DeSoto and Charlotte counties
tomorrow to survey some of the damage oh
I'm sure that'll help that's the first
time I've seen here's the thing this is
the first time I've seen Marco Rubio in
a long time and you didn't even see him
here they're just talking about it the
only time I saw him was when he was
doing the interview on Fox News to talk
about how he was you know helping and
then or it was CNN I forget what I think
it was CNN right I almost feel like
Marco Rubio's AI at this point he's not
even a really you know he pops in I mean
he's just and he just shows up on screen
barely drink water right he's like
glitching a bit it's like he's not even
really a senator he doesn't vote on
anything no and when he does vote he
votes against his State's interest just
kind of you know on brand because one I
think this stupid guy voted against it
right
hurricane uh
uh relief
and then accuses Biden about holding the
funds right of course gotta love it oh
it gets better here watch how he accuses
Biden of not declaring a major disaster
which is not even a thing and uh help
some of the people that we can to ensure
that we're getting the resources there
but I signed a major disaster
declaration letter to the president he
still hasn't signed that we're asking
the president to do that we have a major
disaster here in my district in this no
[ __ ]
okay there is no such thing as a major
disaster declaration there is a there is
there is a declaration of natural
disaster that the president declares not
a congressperson that he has already
done yeah he's already done that and the
host here is really confused watch this
this is on Fox News folks even the host
is like what in the [ __ ] hell what in
the Q Anon [ __ ] are you talking about
here listen to this
the State of Florida and we need help we
need that signed so that Congress can
enact uh and Congress needs to act to
bring supplemental funding down here to
Florida well it's my understanding that
the president had already declared a
disaster area you're looking for a major
disaster declaration there's a
difference
yeah he has to sign the major disaster
declaration in order to unleash a lot of
the federal funding resources that we
need here this is the same Q Anon
[ __ ] and he is a congressman who
voted against that supplemental funds
that he's talking about that Joe Biden
has to sign some kind of imaginary Q
Anon major disaster declaration from the
from the pew pew Scooby-Doo guy listen
listen all this is [ __ ] nonsense you
[ __ ] buffoons out there still
supporting these idiots it's all
buffoonery and they are tricking you
into believing a bunch of garbage and
nonsense this stuff does not even exist
this major disaster declaration that
that a congressman would send to the
president it's nice that congressmen
send letters to the president during
times of natural disaster saying hey I'm
in this district and this is what I need
for my district Mr President because the
president ultimately is the executor of
the executive branch and they direct
FEMA and they get actually put people on
the ground in those congressman's
districts if they would be I don't know
couple to [ __ ] reality but this guy
this guy doesn't he is lying on Fox News
he's lying to you hey fake Gabe are you
in the chat he's lying to people like
you you dumb [ __ ] are gonna
believe what this guy says and he's
lying to you I mean here's here's the
facts right the bill was presenting this
resolution right 230 to 201 they're only
10 Republicans back in it Joe Biden
obviously I was I think it was uh
September 29th put out that you can find
it on the [ __ ] White House website
September 29th
however none of the 16 House Republicans
from Florida backed the legislation
which would have delivered billions of
dollars in relief to their state of
Florida in the aftermath of hurricane
Ian to to [ __ ] [ __ ] on Biden yep
[ __ ] on their people in their state
because really honestly that's what
they're saying is we don't give a [ __ ]
about the people who vote for us it's
only it's only about trumpism that's it
full stop it's all about perpetuating
that Joe bad didn't real and he's not a
real president and all this nonsense
when people in Florida
are suffering there are people who lost
[ __ ] everything anything that they
didn't have on their [ __ ] backs some
of them lost their goddamn lives because
these people play these stupid [ __ ]
games and you dumb [ __ ] out
there who still support this [ __ ] who
are still sick of Fanning for them are
the reason why they're doing it they're
not doing it because it feels good to
them they're doing it because you're
loud about it and you will believe
anything they [ __ ] say even some
stupid ass lie that a Fox News host is
like some some nobody on Fox and he's
just like what the [ __ ] is a major
disaster what the [ __ ] is that what are
you talking you're a congressman and you
voted against the supplemental support
sent to Florida you voted against it
and you're saying that Joe Biden has to
sign your declaration so that there's
extra funds or some dumb [ __ ] that
doesn't exist it's not a thing that what
he just said all that he just said is
all 100 percent stacked up [ __ ] all
of it not a thing
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ] the other you know it
it really comes back to you know for
anyone out there fake Gabe and other
Republicans America whatever you want to
call yourselves nowadays uh fascist uh
if you want to
debate the facts please go look at the
voting record right I just told you who
voted against it I just told you what it
would have done and here's the thing
those Republicans want to bash Joe Biden
and dart Brandon and all the other
[ __ ] democrats for the fact that
they're like well they didn't they
didn't want to give them money they
didn't want to help our our constituents
out when the reality is you look at the
[ __ ] voter log and you say oh look
the Republicans voted against it right
and then they want to be the ones that
[ __ ] about it and they want to say oh
they're not helping us guys they're
they're they're trying they're leaving
us out to dry
and it's really it's the people that are
supposed to be representing the people
of Florida that are leaving their
constituents out to drive they're
they're leaving them out to dry after
this this
insane
uh what what did Ron DeSantis call it a
500 year event right right you know well
so so historic Gabe so historic he he
made sure not to warn the people of Lee
County right it's [ __ ] craziness how
fake Gabe is in the chat he says look
into the supplemental fun dot dot dot
what are you talking about yeah we are
they are gonna have to look into it fake
Abe because Republicans in the State of
Florida are probably going to steal it
they're probably going to [ __ ] steal
it dummy
because you just you're like yeah
Biden needs to sign uh Captain
Scooby-Doo's major disaster relief so
that way if people in Florida get an
extra amount but that's not a thing it's
a it's of all [ __ ] just like
everything else is [ __ ] and we're
gonna get into [ __ ] and it stack
some [ __ ] with the Q Anon even if
like even if you wanted to I mean feel
free to throw it in there and we can
actually look at it and see what
nonsense are talking about but even if
you were to say like oh there's
supplemental stuff that's going in there
you're gonna you're gonna say that
billions of dollars should not go to
these people that just had their homes
ruined
right it
dummy the whole thing is pork it's all
our tax dollars going to help Florida
you dumb [ __ ] what don't you get
fake game I've told you this a thousand
times pluck your head out of your ass
all of it the whole bill all the FEMA
money all the disaster money is not
money that was gonna go to Florida it's
all pork to help Floridians
to rebuild their state after something
that they couldn't control nor us nor
the government could control a natural
disaster and all that government money
all that socialist money all of it the
every [ __ ] single penny of it is
socialist all of it is supplemental all
of it is pork you dumb [ __ ] so
either it's one or the other either you
are okay either you are okay with
leaving Floridians high and dry in this
time of need when their communities have
been absolutely devastated and destroyed
and because of Ronda Santa's more lives
lost or or you just want to leave them
out in the cold or you'll want to help
them it's all pork dummy all of it it's
so [ __ ] stupid I mean fake Gabe is
probably also the person that said uh
money for people that can't work during
the pandemic nah you can go [ __ ]
yourself right that's exactly who I
think
I mean guys let's look at this again
Republicans don't actually follow
Christian values they won't shelter you
they won't feed you they won't they
won't give you uh resources to make sure
that you're okay during a goddamn 500
year event that comes through no you
know what will happen is you'll have uh
you'll have Donald Trump from his
Mar-A-Lago estate the room in which the
FBI took those classified documents that
he stole from our government and then
say guys listen I need some money I need
some money right now because I'm poor
help me I'm poor that's what it was
while people were suffering in Florida
he didn't say hey let's help the people
of Florida and he said help me help me
right now because I'm a criminal and I'm
gonna go down I'm [ __ ] well here's
here's fake Gabe's response he's like oh
look Rick Scott Marco Rubio wrote a
letter they wrote a letter they wrote a
letter
thanks fake game I'm so glad that
Senator Rubio and Rick Scott wrote a
letter did you not just hear what the
[ __ ] I said I just said it's really nice
when Congress people and elected
officials write letters to the president
United States understand what the [ __ ]
you're saying dummy understand what the
[ __ ] you're saying the Democrats control
the Senate Appropriations Committee you
stupid bastard it's the Democrats that
are going to give the money
because they control the house they
control the Senate they control the
executive branch you stupid [ __ ] so when
you when you say oh Rick Scott and Marco
Rubio writing letters they're making
sure that Democrats do their job while
they're not you stupid [ __ ] I'm telling
you fake Gabe you're just better off
you're just better off coming here and
listening and just listen to what the
[ __ ] I say I'm telling you you will be
much better off in the long run and I'm
not just talking to fake ape I mean I am
but I'm talking about all the people who
come here who hate watches listen I'm
telling you if you would just listen to
what the [ __ ] I'm saying for half a
second if you would listen to what I
said to 15 minutes ago when I was
talking about Captain Scooby-Doo and his
derelict ass as a member of Congress the
people who voted for him should be
ashamed they should be out in the
streets right now calling for him to
resign because he was on Fox News lying
about their aid after he saying oh it's
all Joe Budden's fight after he voted
against it the pork gave the pork you
dumb [ __ ] that's the whole thing
that is mind-boggling that you people
don't even understand that all the money
that's going to go to Florida all of it
all of it that now is going to Florida
is all because of Democrats all of it
not because of Republicans let me let me
show you I got another video I want to
show you speaking of this [ __ ] speaking
of Democrats uh and and Republicans
Democrats given socialism and
Republicans only liken when they get to
take credit for you let me show you this
video I found this is um this is not a
surprise actually but this is this is on
brand oh look look who it is look who it
is opposing opposing pork and then
taking credit for it fake Gabe you dumb
bastard let's listen the 1.9 trillion
dollar bill it's kind of Washington at
its worst all public school teachers
will be receiving a one thousand dollar
payment under our budget that means
we're proud of that if you were in the
Senate would you have voted for the
president's package no probably not
Governor Mike dewine is proposing to use
175 million dollars from the federal
government's coveted Relief Fund to pay
for new policing efforts we intend to
give them that help much money it's just
way too much way too much money 100
million more dollars from the American
Rescue plan will go toward addressing
Iowa's housing shortage it's too
important to really do anything else
important it's too important fake Gabe I
don't know if you just heard what the
[ __ ] was just played okay I don't I
don't know if you're starting to
understand or not probably not because
you got your [ __ ] head so far up
Trump's ass
that you can smell the Big Mac he had
for lunch three days ago but here's the
thing
in Florida and this is the reason why
for three days I said Rhonda Santos is
gonna [ __ ] this up because I don't have
to guess I don't have to guess there's
no guessing I know exactly who Ron
DeSantis is I've watched what he's done
I know exactly how he's going to handle
FEMA money I know exactly how he's going
to handle funding he's going to run
around the state in the places he wants
to run around in taking credit for all
the money that only Democrats Gabe only
Democrats [ __ ] voted for the
Republicans in Florida said [ __ ] no we
don't want Floridians to have socialist
money because it might be pork it's all
pork all of it it's really stupid [ __ ]
but you know this is how we gotta treat
dummies in this country you just gotta
go at them and uh you know if fake games
like he's never done that before I mean
do I need to remind you about the 22
million that he took and awarded you
know for uh Broadband infrastructure and
Workforce Development in the Florida
communities but at the same time also
saying I'm not taking a single dime from
that goddamn socialist infrastructure
bill that Joe Biden wants
see here's the same dumb [ __ ] here's the
same dumb [ __ ] where's the bill oh wanna
link me to it no dude it's a simple
[ __ ] search it's not it's not
difficult if you can come here in the
chat and start yapping up a bunch of
dumb trumpism [ __ ] you can go out on the
internet and search this stuff it's a
thing you can do we also know you know
the the do your own research group here
right can't do that knows how to search
because I know for a fact that people
like fake Gabe do not have any of those
like uh articles sub-article topic
0.3.2.1 type of uh actual bills like
memorized in their minds they come in
they copy and they paste what they think
is making their point what they believe
is going to be helping them in in
producing their argument uh so we know
that you know how to search we know that
you can go on to [ __ ] you know
dogpile.com or lycos or ask Jeeves or
any of those other [ __ ] dumb [ __ ]
search engines yeah Steve still exists
it's still there it does I don't know I
didn't know that I haven't been there in
a long time I remember when asked Jesus
was like that was the [ __ ] deal right
that's how you did your own research
back then
um here I want to I really want to go to
The Oath Keepers trial because there's
stuff happening there's news breaking
over there but I really don't want to
not get focused in on how [ __ ]
Republicans are totally gonna [ __ ] up
this Florida thing because they're
Republicans and repo that's the that's
the biggest reason why is because they
are indecent they have no empathy
they're only out for themselves and out
for their power they do not give a [ __ ]
about governing they don't care about
policy they don't care about their
constituents they only care about their
own [ __ ] power and here's Chuck
V
he tweets hey [ __ ] the storm hit
Naples and Fort Myers people walk around
dazed homeless and have lost everything
but you're in Saint Augustine
60 Sunny not a single downed tree to be
seen how is the distribution of Federal
Aid that has been providing going do
your job and he gives him the middle
finger because here's Ron DeSantis he
tweeted was on the ground today with the
folks of Saint Augustine area assessing
the damage
and then he hashtags hurricane Ian we
are working hard to get Floridians back
on on their feet here he is
in a picture oh well that that that
looks oh how nice he's walking stoically
down the street Gabe oh looks really
Brave there in Saint Augustine so tough
he is tough big rock he's so tough going
through he make sure he gets look how
he's cleaned up look how he cleaned up
this neighborhood so fast wow and then
this one he's like no hurricane came
through right and here he is here he is
posing with his his fascist police
because you know these fascists they
attract these [ __ ] stupid types that
are in our law enforcement yeah that
should be [ __ ] purged from these
mogula these moglodytes in our
lawnmowers and it should be [ __ ]
purged from our law enforcement these
[ __ ] pieces of Traders [ __ ] standing
next to this [ __ ] in Saint
Augustine act like he's doing them look
at this what the [ __ ] look how look how
he cleaned Ellie maybe even put even put
new windows and a new porch on this
house back here look at that already
Rhonda Santa's putting the trees back up
in Saint Augustine he is he is such a
great governor of the state of what a
piece of [ __ ] somehow he went to the
other side of the state and helped them
out when you know they did not have
obviously the degree of level of damage
that
um the the Le the the west side of of
the state received right I mean that's
just the typical [ __ ] you know I mean
just for perspective that's you know
that's the same side of the state that
uh Trump is on right right well uh and
and that that's the same side of the
state where Trump was in his little uh
his treason office where he where he he
he sold our our government secrets or
destroyed him or gave him away because
we find out over the weekend that Nara
said we're still missing [ __ ]
um but he was like please give me some
some couch change I know that I know
that the flood's coming in but
Floridians if you if you can hear me
give me your money because I'll save you
from the storm I'll send Rhonda Santos
out to Saint Augustine to save you but
also the other don't forget that that
Donald Trump was in Florida and used
that as an attempt to avoid his
appearance on Friday which was his
deposition so he was able to avoid the
deposition on a long in his in the
lawsuit by going to Mar-A-Lago and
saying I'm stuck in Mar-A-Lago there's a
there's a hurricane I can't get out of
here I'm gonna ride this out but at the
same time then he makes a you know from
the same same place that he made a video
just before that to say I need your
money right now I'm desperate I need
money I need it right now that's so
desperate again he could have taken such
as an opportunity to be like oh [ __ ]
there are people on the west side of the
state who are going to lose their homes
they're going to lose their livelihood
they need our help but instead he said
nah give me the money like in the most
tone deaf way possible this guy is going
to unbrand ask for money when it he
doesn't actually you know when other
people need it I mean I know that he's
broke and he actually needs it and his
money's tied up with these super Pacs
and he's using them for his legal issues
but man of all the times
you couldn't wait a week you couldn't do
it later on like you had to hit your
September 30th quarter three deadline
that was the best opportunity you had
was to say give me money and that's not
the only thing too I had [ __ ] Donald
Trump Jr texting me on my burner number
to say hey my dad needs your money he
needs your money we got a big important
deadline coming up he really he really
is him and Ivanka beg you for money all
the time dude it's not Ivanka begging me
for money for Trump
it's she's doing it by proxy of Jared's
book so she says my husband wrote this
book blah blah blah they're giving away
[ __ ] like if you donate a hundred
dollars which they like suggest and then
they're like rattling 250 when you get
to the donation site which is like wow
what kind of donations do you think
people can make damn right like 50 20
like five dollars that's like the normal
like well they need people to be given
thousands of dollars God damn it but
these legal bills are not gonna pay
themselves when this criminal goes to
federal prison not only that but they've
already you know again they're
pre-checking the monthly recurring
donations so people like what the [ __ ]
they've already had to return 135
million dollars and that's just from 20
2020 and 2021 so like this is something
that is a dumb Shady tactic that Trump
does but by having Ivanka ask for a book
they're giving away memorabilia and like
other swag and [ __ ] to be like hey we'll
we'll sweeten the deal if you give us a
hundred if you give us 250 we'll throw
in this book by Jared because they can't
sell it anyways right we'll throw in
this mug we'll throw in this hat we'll
throw in this Trump end whatever it
might be they're trying to get you know
what maybe we should try that here
listen if you if you send us 500 I'll
send you a dark Brandon shirt hell I'll
send you Jared kushner's book so you can
burn it yeah I'll do that hell yeah send
me 500 bucks I'll I'll send you Jared
kushner's book so you can burn it and
send you a dark brain and shirt hell
yeah I mean I don't know I I'm just I
guess we're not as good at grifting as
this [ __ ] speaking of off the
rails now you said he claimed that he
couldn't leave the state because of the
hurricane but he did leave the state he
did he went to Warren Michigan
apparently yeah this is the same type of
stuff that he was like oh guys I can't I
can't deal with uh Leticia James right
now my previous wife Ivana Trump died
and then he's that well yeah he had to
stuff that casket full of documents
three days later that weekend he's like
oops Got a rally gotta go to manager
well I mean these Nazi rallies aren't
gonna Nazi themselves right they're just
not I mean the the Q Anon leader has to
show up uh for the Seance but listen to
here he finally got the memo game he
finally got the memo that we've all been
saying out loud he finally got it I
don't know how many times we've had to
say it and send it but he finally got it
listen Free Speech Crush religious
liberty confiscate your guns
indoctrinate your children criminalize
dissent and even put their political
opponents in prison I think they'd like
to see me in prison can you imagine I
think that like you know why you know
why because they're sick they're sick
people okay he says this to a crowd who
not but minutes later
minutes later get into the chant that
they that they coined during his first
election in 2016 to lock up his
political opponent lock her up to
Hillary Clinton this is absolutely if it
if it wasn't if it wasn't real you
couldn't write it I mean you just can't
it's [ __ ] crazy ass [ __ ] and yes
Donald Trump people who want
criminals to be held accountable want
you to go to prison yes they do that is
what they want because we know that
you've committed crime not just one not
just in one state not just in one
jurisdiction not just on one issue you
are a [ __ ] criminal and We Know It
everyone knows it your [ __ ] business
is criminally charged regardless of what
the fake Gable type in the chat right
they're criminally charged and they're
civilly civil under civil suit now
and he's under criminal investigation in
a grand jury for January 6 in Washington
DC he's under he's under criminal
investigation in Florida for stealing
our top secret documents and harboring
them and possibly destroying them
and selling them I don't know what what
do you think because
um did Nara actually say how many they
were missing they didn't actually say
how many they were just like um all that
[ __ ] we got all that all that [ __ ]
the 11
000 documents 200 000 pages of documents
or whatever they're like we still don't
have it all now
we still don't get it he's still got
something he says he goes I don't have
anything his lawyers say we don't have
anything they say no we have we know you
have something so then they're like all
right fine we have some stuff and we
have the signed document that says we're
pretty sure we gave you anything or
actually I'm not pretty sure we know we
gave you everything then it's revealed
that oh he's got stuff stored you know
in other places like the basement
they're like we'll put a [ __ ] lock on
it so that no one can go in there
specifically you doesn't listen they
have to end up coming in and by legal
search go in and say we're taking the
[ __ ] documents because you kept lying
to us and we want what's ours because
it's not yours and then he keeps trying
to fight it and they're like all right
we're pretty sure that we got everything
and now we find out that it doesn't they
don't have everything which means yeah
you might have to check a casket of a
certain someone that was actually
cremated I actually had I actually
tweeted there I tweeted I said check the
casket baby I don't know I mean like we
all joked about it before and I know
like people are like I might want to
check the casket some people were joking
some people were serious and now we're
like maybe legitimately there might be
something in there when you would
normally have six pallbearers carrying a
casket you have 10 which is like why are
there additional papers headings
payments it's really heavy you've got
the video of him going uh to his private
jet and there's eight boxes that are
being carried of of legal kind of uh you
know boxes so you then have to wonder
like what were those where did those
were those collected or are they also in
a place that might house a body but was
also cremated and in the ground uh that
it was was a golf course but now is
technically a cemetery right this is and
the same you know for the same uh
ex-wife that Trump said I can't go to
this deposition in New York because my
my ex-wife just passed away and then you
find out a few days later he goes to a
rally on Saturday because of course you
can't stop the Griff Tony you gotta let
it go well yeah I mean you would go
broke I'm gonna point on something Dave
here I've been enjoying pointing out
these [ __ ] stupid maglodites in the
chat maybe they'll learn a thing or do
Dave you really are a dumb [ __ ]
number one the Lincoln project is not
Democrats they're not Democrats they're
[ __ ] Republicans dummy they're
Republicans
they're let me let me let me say it's
slower for you they're Republicans
they're not Trump Republicans because
they're not stupid right but they're
Republicans you people really do you
really do need to take take the time
before you come up in the chat because
you're not going to get many past me I
mean I'm not going to see every comment
but your nonsense in the Chant isn't
going to last very long because I'm
going to start calling you out because I
like it I'm I'm enjoying myself this is
like really this is therapy for me here
to just absolutely eviscerate you
speaking of eviscerating people very
easily here's another one that's very
easily eviscerated because she is a dumb
[ __ ]
um apparently Gabe she's getting
divorced what do we know about this has
anything else developed other than she's
been served and she wants privacy on
this manner but nothing else the I
haven't heard anything uh in addition to
yeah it was released I mean we know that
I think
certain documents were sealed
in their their court appearance some of
the stuff came out but I think other
things were sealed in there so this is
uh
something that we haven't really heard
much development on I mean like
it really goes back to the fact like
this woman a a a Christian nationalist
we'll even break it down a Christian I
mean she's a Nazi but she's a Christian
right she's a Christian so far from
Christian right yeah yeah we'll put that
in quotes because you know she's not
she's the one who breaks the Ten
Commandments right who you know has an
affair multiple times over the years her
husband stays with her for whatever
reason they try to work through it or
because of a Public Image thing or a
business or whatever it might be
then we come to a point which is
none of those accusations were denied
she said oh it's all fake news it's
defamation if it really was defamation
she could have easily taken these people
to court she would have made a [ __ ]
buttload of money from The Daily Mail
the son anyone who published anything
about her having an affair and accusing
her of having an affair she could have
taken him to court but she never did
because it's a true story right you have
the people who were involved they came
forward one guy was like I don't want
anything to do with that woman anymore
she's [ __ ] nuts the other guy who was
the tantric sex guru was like uh no
comment I don't want to really talk
about this
uh and then we also find out that over
the years she has other people that she
slept with openly having affairs with
her neighbors and other family people
were like oh man
okay that that's what it is yeah but
this was years ago right right this is
years ago we don't know what happened
also between 2012 2013 up until right
before she started running right you
know people joke about her and Matt
Gates might be a thing I have no idea is
it possible totally why not Matt Gates
is also [ __ ] creep so you know what
you know birds of a feather flock
together right so nothing new has been
has come out yet I'm sure more will come
out because now that this has happened
people are very [ __ ] curious about
this woman who we knew was a hypocrite
and was projecting it everything she had
the woman who stands up for family
values would right easily
degrade those and try to say that she's
the I'm a real Christian right yeah well
of course she is of course well we what
we got we got some comments coming in
here there's some comments coming and
flowing it throwing in from the
megalodites and I'm just having so much
fun they're setting themselves up on the
T for me to knock them out of the park
Dave
um soy boy so let's let's address this
because I believe Gabe this this Harkens
back to the idea that I as a child would
have drank soy milk I think is the I
think is the the thing and soy milk has
estrogen in it this is really dumb [ __ ]
by the way to think that just because
you drink soy milk means you have more
estrogen but here's the thing Dave I
grew up on a farm I grew up on a farm we
had like real [ __ ] milk buddy like
the real thing so enough of the soy boy
stuff you're you're barking up the wrong
tree there I don't know if you heard my
voice
but you're you're in hillbilly World
here and Gabe oh this is beautiful this
plays right into the what we're talking
about with Marjorie Taylor green he says
70 in the nation is Christian fake game
sets thank you for saying what I can let
them know what Democrats really think
about them he didn't he he said
Christian she's not a Christian she's
not one now I'm I'm an atheist I think I
think Gabe is self-proclaiming atheist
we grew up in the Catholic church both
of us
which makes us raised catholic christian
whatever the hell you want to call it
here's the thing when I was growing up
and they were you know trying to pump my
mind full of stuff to to indoctrinate me
with my that their religion
none of it none of it had to do with
what trumpism and what Trump and what
his allies come out on stage and say
none of that none of none of them
Christian morals none of the Jesus stuff
Jesus this Jesus that none of that is
what they're doing none of that so 70 of
the nation may be Christian and that may
be why Joe Biden get eight million more
votes in the last election and that's
why I believe that trumpism is going to
get piled under mountains of votes in
this election and here's Jeremy oh
Jeremy everyone knows Jeremy is a piece
of [ __ ] Jeremy's a piece of [ __ ] why is
it why are they all on Facebook by the
way have you noticed that that these
[ __ ] pieces of [ __ ] are awesome Mark
Zuckerberg we're trying to suppress
their vote did you hear this this
morning that they that they wouldn't let
me put the title
if you go to Facebook they would not let
me put the title I the title today for
today's show is Oath Keepers on trial
for Trump treason that's the title for
today now when I move the ability to put
a title when I well no when I put in the
title face it said it gave me a warnings
like Facebook rejected your title try
again [ __ ] so I so I took off Trump
trees and I'm like okay I get it I went
a little overboard as I always do and
should do here at the Tony Michaels
podcast so I changed the title to Oath
Keepers on trial for sedition that's
just a pure blooded fact yeah I'm not
making anything up they're literally on
trial today fake news no that's real
[ __ ] Facebook wouldn't even let me type
that in
they're like nope try again try again
try again
so so I just took the whole title off
and just put the Tony Michaels podcast
episode number 240. huh because because
they wouldn't let me they wouldn't let
me type in that that [ __ ] that that
title I don't know I have no idea I mean
they're silencing me they're gonna
cancel this game oh it's Facebook
they're gonna
no so listen it's their platform they
can be they can be in support of
sedition and The Oath Keepers if they
would like uh a lot like guys like here
like Jeremy who says you know King David
had an affair did you know that game
that King David she had an affair
okay Jeremy you're only proving our
Point you're only proving our point
there buddy
um so I want to go back to this real
quick I'm sorry I had to I had to do the
whole Chat thing people I think people
like when I go after these [ __ ]
I just I can't I can't help it it just
so funny people try to use uh either
verses from the Bible or try to use you
know historical moments of something to
bolster their point of look this is
actually the opposite so like when
Marjorie Taylor green is not actually oh
my God here it hears Gabe again he says
fake Gabe says seditious conspiracy not
sedition uh all right all right all
right all right okay
fake game you this just proves how dumb
you really are that if I say Oath
Keepers are on trial for sedition you're
like no seditious conspiracy they're on
trial you're admitting they're on trial
then you're admitting that there was
enough evidence for a grand jury to
place charges on them and they're on
trial today and we're going to get to
that I know we're 35 minutes into the
second hour so let's let's get to to the
space laser lunatic here see what she
had to say so we can move on to some
oathkeepers news I want to actually show
fake Gabe and Jeremy and Dave here in
the Facebook Chat what kind of [ __ ]
treason they're supporting well let's
let's listen to this treasonous piece of
[ __ ]
we're all Targets now though for daring
to push back against the regime and it
doesn't stop at a weaponized legal
system I'm not going to mince words with
you all Democrats want Republic instead
and they've already started the killings
an 18 year old boy was run down found by
a Democrat driver who confessed to
killing the teenagers simply because he
was a republican okay so I don't know
what happened with a car accident or
someone getting hit and killed or a
teenager getting killed
but my guess is I'm just gonna guess
this really quickly that almost likely
that because she said it it's absolutely
Q Anon nonsense so let's let's move on
from that we'll we'll do a little bit of
our own research there but let's let's
keep going here with the space laser
lunatic
even right here in Michigan just last
week an 83 year old woman was shot in
the back for advocating for The Unborn
[Music]
okay again I'm not saying that an 83
year old woman was not shot in the back
I'm not saying that but
it really is suspicious when this [ __ ]
says it into a microphone I'm just
saying might want to check in on it
might not want to just take it for fact
yep Joe Biden has declared every freedom
loving American and Enemy of the State
but under Republicans we will take back
our country from the Communists who have
stolen it and want us to disappear
do you mean the Communist who voted for
relief in Florida a state that is just
south of you
is that is that is that the Communist
that you're talking about is that the
are they sit the same ones the same Kami
red Kami bastards that you're I don't
know I'm just I'm just wondering what
communist she's talking about here
we will expose the unelected bureaucrats
the real enemies within who have abused
their power and declared political
Warfare on the greatest president this
country has ever had is she talking
about Obama oh no no she's running back
then so I looked up by the way I looked
up the story about this uh the [ __ ]
that she's spewing North Dakota you know
North Dakota cop slapped out here here's
the thing
this this guy in North Dakota
uh ran over and killed this 18 year old
right yes that's no dispute there that
happened right police in North Dakota
said there's that
right police in North Dakota said that
there's no evidence
showing that politics were involved when
I fatally struck a teenager with his SUV
I mean the local police you mean the
local police yep
you might as well you might as well just
stop saying it right now because here's
the thing
they've slapped it down they threw it
out they said no this was not a
motivation that was political it it was
not something it was like I'm gonna
[ __ ] chase down this person because
of their political involvement that is
not the case so that's one then there's
also this woman who is 83 yes she was
she got shot so I'm right so I'm right
so there was a teenager ran over and
there was a lady shot in the back okay
he was shot while passing out pamphlets
that's what the prosecutor says uh I
gotta read more into this but it says
she was shot on the shoulder on
September 20th after some verbal
altercation at a county residence
uh no exactly okay wait wait wait wait
wait so she was on someone's private
property and they were a gun owner you
know this sounds this sounds really
familiar and it sounds like almost a
narrative
that they would be for protecting their
Castle because a lot of states have a
castle doctrine where you can't come on
someone's private property and they can
actually use lethal force with a firearm
which they say they're for they're
really for those two April Bros and I'm
sure Jeremy Gabe and Dave will be agree
with me here that boy you just had rat
shoot anyone anytime you want especially
when it's on your property 2A man 2A
right 2A so basically this woman came up
and she got shot in the shoulder she's
fine she was released from the hospital
and she's she's fine so not really I
mean kind of shot in the back but not
she made it sound like she died yeah
with the wall of course if you leave it
shot in the back and you don't explain
what happened then of course it's gonna
sound like especially as you proceed it
with this 18 year old kid was run over
by someone in a car in North Dakota and
this 83 year old woman this frail woman
because that's what they're leading up
to was shot in the back
and then you move on you don't explain
what happened so in other words there
was an altercation because this woman
approached them on their property God
knows what the political affiliation he
just didn't want her on the property
right and and in in the in in [ __ ]
Maga land you just shoot someone because
they don't do what you want them to do
so in other words they should be in
support of this person using their
Second Amendment right on this what
whoever this woman was so again I'm just
trying to just trying to fact check
right people in real time live fact
checking live online fact checking okay
so there was one more Q Anon rally
before I get those Keepers because we
only got about 20 minutes and I know if
we go through these threads with these
this oathkeeper news I'm sure um we're
gonna have plenty of it here the other
thing I want to ask you about is Kim
Kardashian real quick too I gotta ask
you about that what the hell is that
story
um with the crypto [ __ ]
um because it seems like a lot of people
are gonna have that problem pimping this
crypto including um uh Matt Damon and
some others but here is a video in a q
Anon rally in Pennsylvania for the
Pennsylvania Mussolini mastriano listen
to this crazy ass [ __ ] that he is saying
to his audience and they believe every
single bit of it ah they love it too
listen on day one the sexualization of
our kids pole dancing and all this other
crap that's going on will be forbidden
in our schools
Gabe did you I I missed when I was nice
and this really pissed me off when I
heard this I'm like wait a second are
you saying are you telling me that I had
a pole dancing class in my elementary
school and I missed out missed out on
that what in the you didn't have that no
I man I really I really missed out I
mean when I could sign up for PE it was
swimming tennis badminton flag football
and pole dancing I had pole dancing and
they were like like all right now what
we're gonna do is did they put you in a
thong no no no no no no no I mean like I
mean like I had to hike my shorts up and
oh we'll tell you this I will tell you
this that's one hell of a Core workout
man I know did they did they teach you
how to twerk twerk is it twerk Turks
twerk oh it's work okay I mean I could I
could go up and down that pole just by
my quads man baby so you took the pole
dancing glass it was great this is all
really stupid right yeah
no one is teaching elementary kids pull
down what in the [ __ ] is he talking
about
what is he number one dancing in and of
itself is a good exercise now pole
dancing I wouldn't imagine myself being
able to do that if you've ever watched
someone actually like an acrobat and
we're not talking about strippers here
because there are the stripper type of
pole dancers but there's acrobats as
well like they're [ __ ] athletes yeah
and there's no way I could do any of
that [ __ ] no [ __ ] way hold yourself
out by your arms on a on a pole or a
ring or whatever the hell it is or even
like circus delay stuff where it's like
with a cloth like amazing
crazy amount of strength right much
stronger than any Republican but let me
tell you when I was in elementary school
they did not teach us pole dancing
but you'll be happy to know Gabe that
they we had square dancing in in
elementary they actually taught our
White
dumbasses how to square dance like it
was a thing it was a requirement that we
did square dancing do you know what
square dancing is I know what square
dancing is did you square dance we
didn't square dance I actually had a
class I actually took a class in my gym
uh in in high school that was tap dance
really you tap dance yeah yeah I would
almost pay money four months to get a
video of you tapping you know what you
should do you should get your green
screen out and do a tap dance and then
like put yourself in all kinds of
different uh yeah good please
for three or four months every morning
from like nine to nine fifty I was tap
dancing in gym class see a lot of people
said they Square danced here in the chat
they're saying they square dance yeah
swing your partner round and round kick
her in the butt and throw her down I
don't know I really don't know I don't
remember okay let's let's let's continue
with the pole dancing talk I guess I I'm
not really sure
on day one all the graphics
pornographic books that are in
elementary schools will be will be
pulled out
wait wait they have porno they have
porno in elementary school okay one
thing I did not have I did not have porn
Elementary why didn't we have the porno
mags in our I did not have porno mags in
the library now Elementary School listen
this is probably what's wrong with me is
I didn't have porno mangs what the [ __ ]
is he talking about porno what are they
talking about like literally you could
go to anyone and really there there's
this story about this [ __ ] this
private school in Florida I don't know
if you've seen this we're in like second
or third grade one of the required
assignments
is for the kids to go home get and read
in the bathtub and they have to send in
a picture as proof submit a picture as
proof that you had that you read in the
bathtub which is really [ __ ] weird I
mean people taking pictures of the
little babies in the bathtub is one
thing but
taking pictures of a third grader in a
bathtub so you can prove that they're
eating that's really [ __ ] that's called
um what's the word that mastriana would
use pornographic yeah what in the [ __ ]
is wrong with this guy no one there's no
porn in elementary school libraries
dummy there's no porn in the [ __ ]
this is craziness let's I mean of course
it's from Florida right right well the
unfortunate thing is whenever you're
like oh is it Florida of course yeah it
was well let's let's finish up with the
porno and pole dancing here
[Music]
on day one and done critical race series
out the window
that's right pull the old card out right
come on
he's like yeah even though no one
believes that [ __ ] anymore come on clap
for it clapboard what the [ __ ] when you
hear a politician or prospective
politician say on the first day I'm
gonna do this on the first day I'm gonna
make like sure on the first day you
could sign whatever you want but also on
the first day this won't even be
available critical race Theory one and
done I'm gonna get it out there right as
I come in I'm signing a bill it's like
okay
do you know how Logistics works you know
how to disseminate information in a rule
or policy even if you said no critical
race Theory and even if critical racer
was actually taught in schools which
it's not
uh you would not be able to get rid of a
program
on the first day
I signed it everyone get [ __ ] uh it's
you can't especially a program and this
is this is really weird because this is
like getting rid of stuff that doesn't
like on day one I'm gonna get rid of
this like yeah that's gonna be really
easy because it doesn't exist right like
it's really easy to get rid of something
that isn't real yeah like you could you
could sign something sure I want to
assign the closure of this I want to
sign this or what have you he should
take all Keebler elves out of schools is
what he should do the real ones not the
cookies right the cookies leave their
cookies but they should not be allowed
to be teaching in school keyboards
themselves those cartoon characters you
know those guys that is the thing if I
was running for governor that's would be
my agenda is is to make sure to get
imaginary things out of schools that's
what I would do and because you would be
guaranteed to be successful because like
the minute he swears in he's like okay I
now get maybe that's what it is it's
this [ __ ]
the the the mind control thing the Trump
declassify so he becomes governor and
he's like he doesn't even have to try
hard right he thinks he thinks he's uh
and then boom pole dancing pornography
and CRT are gone from elementary schools
and he's like I just got rid of all them
because I thought it and like yeah it
didn't exist well it's also Doug
mastriano is like he kind of you know
he's he's got a shaved bald head right
he's kind of maybe he's going for that
uh Professor X kind of thing where he's
like you know I'm gonna tell you right
now with my telepathic Powers I will
force everyone to do what I say his
trumpet maybe it's a tinfoil hat fits
better
just the idea it's like I can think it
so you will do it are we just taking
away Free Will and now you're saying you
have to follow my regime if I tell you
to do something you've got to do it
sounds a lot like fascism yeah right
well when they have scary things that
don't exist and they're going to get rid
of them things that don't exist right to
make a problem and then they try to fix
the problem but it was never a problem
to begin with
here here talking about fixing things up
um Carrie Johnson is in the courtroom
she is I believe NPR reporter for
justice
um she's live tweeting
um here this was at 10 46 my time so it
was at 11 46 so just about an hour ago
um she says prosecutor Jeffrey nessler
plays audio of Stuart Rhodes this is
audio that they're playing this is the
problem that they're gonna have in this
courtroom and by they I mean all
Republicans everywhere who still support
Trump and still support the idea that he
won and they like January 6th and they
call the January 6th
um insurrectionists and seditionist
Patriots here's the problem they're
gonna have
sure Rose allegedly said on January 10th
this is the date of January 10th so four
days after he tried to overthrow the
government he said quote in the audio
recording
this isn't like hearsay this is an Audi
this isn't hearsay fake Gabe I just want
to make sure you're listening very
closely here
my only regret is that they should have
brought rifles this is Stuart Rhodes
saying us he said you're telling me
there's audio of Elmer Stewart Rhodes on
January 10th four days after the
Insurrection him saying that he wishes
that he had weapons at the Capitol to
make sure they got done what they wanted
to do here was the quote here was the
quote we could have fixed it up right
then and there wow with weapons this is
an audio recording of Stuart do you want
to know why Stuart Rose didn't want to
go on trial do you want to know why they
didn't want Stuart Rose to go on trial
this audio do you know why do you know
why the January 6th select committee is
kind of like well our peering isn't
going to mean [ __ ] anymore the reason
why is because this trial is going to
walk all over what January 6 the select
committee had planned to show the
American people because this is going to
be way more wild and way more [ __ ]
seditious than the evidence of January 6
select committee was willing to present
to the American people the federal
prosecutors listen to me when I say this
the federal prosecutors have way more
evidence against Stewart Rhodes and The
Oath Keepers than the January 6th select
committee could ever dream of having
there is nothing nothing standing in a
way of a federal prosecutor seeking
discovery not a God damn thing not a
[ __ ] thing stands in their way it is
a criminal investigation there is a
criminal indictment by a grand jury and
they have the right to Discovery and
Buddy are we gonna see some [ __ ]
Discovery and this is just one of them
that I picked out in this string of
tweets let's see if we we can find
something else is do you have any um can
you check Scott McFarlane I think he was
gonna show up and I think Glenn uh
kirschner was also can you check their
account to see if they have anything
while I uh check carries feed here but
that was the one thing I pulled out
earlier
um is this audio uh again it is going to
be absolutely devastating uh to not not
just not just Stuart Rhodes because
still roads is going to get 30 years
this did you know this trial is
estimated to last six to seven weeks and
it's because of the evidence it's
because of the discovery so normally a
federal trial that is kind of a quote
unquote slam dunk
um you would expect especially if the
discovery evidence is leaning towards
that that's why most people don't go to
Federal trials they just don't do it
because they're gonna [ __ ] lose more
than likely
um
so most federal trials you know the last
several weeks but the ones that have
mountains of evidence just mountains of
evidence take a long time because the
prosecution has to work their way
through that Discovery and they have to
present the case to the to the jury and
when you look at their predictions of
this they're saying that the prosecution
is probably going to take three weeks
to present Discovery and that Stewart
Rhodes defense is maybe going to last a
week that is not a good sign not just
for Stuart roads because Stewart Rhodes
is going to get if he gets convicted
here on some of these charges especially
seditious conspiracy he's going to get
what is called a dirty 30. he's going to
get 20 years and he's going to get 10
years probation so he's going to serve
30 years in the federal system now the
the and probably his likely his
co-conspirators here will also receive
that but the most important thing is
this idea that the [ __ ] January 6
insurrectionists Were Somehow Patriots
and they were just trying to make sure
that Donald Trump won his rightful
election is all a bunch of [ __ ] and
this criminal trial that is only going
to be coupled to [ __ ] facts and
evidence and it's going to be said out
of Stuart Road's mouth we're already
seeing that and we're probably going to
see Roger Stone's
um Communications here in this trial so
it looks like you sent something over
from Scott here here yeah there's a
couple of the first one that I sent was
him just saying like no they'll they
will hear from Stuart Rhodes but it'll
be over a six to seven week period the
second one I think will be pretty
interesting to show too yeah so so this
is uh this is Scott McFarland a friend
of the show here and a great reporter by
the way um if you want to follow someone
who's absolutely dedic and I don't even
understand how this guy keeps track of
all this [ __ ] to be quite honest crazy
this I I don't know what kind of [ __ ]
like CRM seditious trees in a CRM that
he has on these people to try to see
what when they did this to pictures but
this guy is on top of it uh Scott's one
of the best at this
um he he says here defense attorney and
opening of oath keeper seditious
conspiracy trial says we're going to get
to hear from Stuart Rhodes himself so
Stewart is going to do the thing that
Dakota his estranged son said he would
do he Dakota really thinks that this guy
is going to try to make a circus out of
this thing which he his attempt is going
to be foiled by his guilt here and it's
not going to impress the jury but um
also Scott goes on to say
gonna be a while though the trial is
estimated at six or seven weeks and
that's and that's what I'm saying Stuart
roads will testify at the end yeah
there'll be the very last part of the
defense's case so they'll because they
don't want him to do it right up front
they're gonna see all the case that they
make they're gonna watch all this stuff
happen they're gonna see how their
defense plays and then Stewart will
testify if he gets to that point because
he may back out and decide not to if
it's really a slam dunk against him
um but my guess is Stewart's an idiot
and he'll do it um so what's the the
second one here from Scott you said this
one's interesting what's this yeah the
next one is also a a uh justification
for why Stuart Rhodes did what he did
okay so this is Stuart Road's defense
this is the quote from the courtroom
Rhodes
um defense attorney said believe in good
faith Trump could invoke the
Insurrection act which we know that we
know that from from jailhouse tapes that
he's recorded with uh what's the [ __ ]
what's that place he that's that
treasonous rag that always
does um interviews with him hey and it's
not on the tip in tibetan they're
they're real good friends with uh Steve
Bannon
um it's a quote here it's why he did
what he did was because he believed
Trump was going to invoke the
Insurrection act folks and and uh there
was a tape from a rally that we showed I
think last week where Stuart Rhodes is
standing there saying the president
needs to do this and that and that but
what
what gives the defense I mean this is a
really stupid defense if I if you're
thinking about it so the defense is
immediately admitting that he was
colluding
he was colluding with Trump because he
believed in good faith
something had to give him good faith
reassurance either either Trump himself
or a proxy you know stodger Roan uh
would have been the communication
channel to say hey if you do these
things then don't worry about it Trump's
got your back he's going to come in and
and make you know uh declare martial law
and and invoke the Insurrection act and
you guys are going to be the people on
the ground who are going to be able to
lock that [ __ ] down
uh and that you know again it's been
like the only reason
he thought he could get away with it the
only reason he planned this type of
thing with all these other people you've
got uh you know Bianca Gracia you've got
uh Enrique tario you've got other people
from either the proud boys or other
organizations that you want to say great
we've got a a collaborative group here
on on site to know everybody's role you
have to do this during this you have to
do that during that you have to make
sure that you guys are armed when we
call in the people across the Potomac
so when you hear someone like Gabe here
say there's no correspondence between
Trump and those groups
um
easy easy big game what you might want
to do fake game before you start making
really stupid statements because I'm
telling you I'm gonna bring this up
later on here it probably is I would
imagine it's going to be within the next
six or seven weeks I would imagine that
I'm gonna bring up this comment that you
just made because we already know there
was correspondence between the White
House and the lady who runs the Latino
for Trump organization that groups those
groups you mean the same lady who met in
the parking garage with the guy who's on
trial today for seditious conspiracy
saying he wish he had rifles so that he
could do what had to be done which was
overthrow the government fake Gabe up
again I know I know I know it is hard to
admit that you're [ __ ] you're wrong
and you're supporting treasonous pieces
of [ __ ] I know it's tough to get that
far but man fake Gabe really honestly if
you came in the chat I would that within
this six or seven week period when this
statement is completely untrue and you
come in the chat into Facebook and say
look guys I was completely wrong I was I
should have been listening to what
everyone was saying I was dumb I I just
I can't I couldn't imagine these people
being treasonous I would bet the
Facebook Chat would welcome me with open
arms I would welcome you with open arms
here on the show and we would be proud
that you finally finally did the thing
that so many trumped up Americans need
to do which is again I say it this way
pluck your head
out of your ass like that just like that
pluck it out Gabe okay I mean look at
this October 3rd let's mark it down Tony
and Gabe are gonna tell you right now
right you're a [ __ ] idiot and that
you're going to see here's the thing did
you set a reminder did you send it I'm
gonna put a reminder in okay yeah just
six weeks because here's the thing we
also might hear this when the committee
comes together so we might get a sample
before they actually showed this in
court depending on right because they
were supposed to show that the one in
the word the word was that they were
going to show some of the connections of
the communications between the Trump
White House and again they gave I know I
know you want to believe [ __ ] but
Mark Meadows Mark Meadows was texting a
lot of people yeah a lot thousands
thousands of text messages and a lot of
those were involving January 6th because
remember and the fake slate of electors
and and he knew I mean Cassidy
Hutchinson came she she took Rudy
Giuliani out to his car because you know
he needs help right and said goodbye and
he was talking about January 6. Cassidy
Hutchinson came back into the office
went to Mark Meadows and said oh man I'm
really kind of upset or kind of like
frazzled about what Rudy Giuliani said
he said that you know Jan 6 is going to
be a bit of a show and things are going
to go down Mark Meadows without
hesitation didn't even acknowledge what
she said and then when she finally got
his attention he was like oh yeah okay
and continue down with this phone
texting I don't know maybe it was
someone like uh Jenny Thomas maybe he
was someone else that was involved but
look
if there's smoke you better [ __ ]
believe there is fire and we have seen
again and again that there's smoke
there's no reason why you know the uh
Elmer Stewart Rhodes would be on trial
if it wasn't for his involvement he's
literally telling people and they're
replaying audio of his actual voice him
actually saying these things we have
we've seen video interviews of him we're
hearing audio where he's literally
admitting to the thing that he did and
then trying to say well the reason I did
it guys was because I was waiting and I
was told that Trump was going to invoke
the Insurrection act so you can't tell
me that this is all hearsay and that
this [ __ ] and that this is made up
when it's literally the guy who's on
trial saying these things on video or in
audio well and even here in Hugo's even
here in Hugo's tweet because Hugo kind
of lays it out here right um from the AP
in Washington and this is goes to this
recording that they're talking about
Capital Riot now prosecutor Oath Keepers
connected he was so he was trying to
type this out so fast that even Hugo
misspelled connected
um quote arm Rebellion no no he's no
it's not gonna it's concocted oh okay
concoction sorry I'm I'm sure terrible
reading uh armed Rebellion to stop
transfer or power by any means any means
necessary
um means necessary uh because we gotta
go we're out of time now we really gotta
go to like six hours a day like eight
days a week okay fake Gabe you said I'll
admit uh me being wrong
will you stop podcasting when you are
wrong is that your fear that's that's
Gabe's fear that I'm talking to a
microphone that is just fear well so
that is his greatest fear and what he's
triggered by is that somebody is you
know telling the truth and I are telling
the truth we're literally just reading
the facts as they well if I could read
if I could read right yeah well you know
he's got to concoct this idea but I'm a
horrible you know I I want to say
something before I go because this this
is really important about the podcasting
thing because fake Gabe I will never I'm
not gonna stop I'm not going to I'm not
going to stop talking to microphone I'm
not gonna stop trying to piss people
like because wait that would that would
be your first amendment right oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm not I'm not
gonna stop it's gonna be something that
I'm going to do even as terrible as a
reader than I am even sometimes when I
mispronounce word like salsa and it gets
it gets Gabe going listen I'm not gonna
stop I won't stop and the reason why
won't start because every single inch of
this democracy is worth fighting for and
you're worth fighting for believe it or
not you are worth fighting for because I
truly believe as dedicated as you are to
the dumb [ __ ]
the dumb [ __ ] that you absolutely
have bought and paid for and I'm not
just talking about fake Gabe himself
he's just the example in the chat this
is this is a disease that has that has
plagued a low percentage well has been
poisoned all right we have a [ __ ]
disease in this country and it is
trumpism and it is fascism and it is Q
Anon it is this crazy white Christian
nationalism that has plagued our country
and it it's not going to go away just by
us ignoring it right we have to call it
out we have to take them head on and
eventually eventually some of them will
come around some of them won't they'll
go take their dirt nap with this
delusion and this sickness that they
have but we have to be vigilant because
we the one thing we can't do we can let
them in the chat and they can have their
little fun and whine and cry about how
they're [ __ ] victims and all this
[ __ ]
like big game does here but the one
thing we cannot let them do as a
democracy is let them have the reins of
power of our government and their hands
on our policies they absolutely 100
percent will take away your rights and
your freedom that is their goal with it
so be vigilant lean into democracy we
only have a few more weeks till this
most important election and I have very
much confidence that it is going to go
in the way of democracy that's why
Republicans are terrified and I didn't
get to Donald Trump threatening Mitch
McConnell that's why he was threatening
Mitch McConnell that's why he was doing
it he's sending death threats because
Mitch McConnell knows they're going to
lose and frankly Mitchell kind of wants
him to lose
he wants him as he knows it's bad for
his power yep he knows it's bad so
everyone stay tuned to the Tony Michaels
podcast we ran out of time um make sure
you go and support us because we run on
your support go to
tonymichaels.livet tip you can give us a
one-time tip or a monthly tip also go to
the merch store
store.e3michaels.com and get your dark
Brandon merch I didn't even get to to
present the the new design that we have
but I'll throw up this old design here
the Rhonda Santos can go [ __ ] himself
because that's gonna be a theme here at
the Tony Michaels podcast for the next
few weeks along with this seditious
conspiracy trial that is going on
so stay tuned don't go anywhere
same time same place tomorrow I know it
seems like a long ways away but it ain't
it's short it's sweet and we're gonna
get there every single weekday two full
hours rather fake gay blanks it or not
Surf's Up Surf's Up [ __ ] you've
been listening to the Tony Michaels
podcast in your face commentary of
current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon